I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense so I know the clothing line how
you decide what goes on it and what like
first off why did you start what is no
no let's back up further hmm
what does death saves mean well it means
a few things I guess I think sent me to
you there's a bit of it that well there
there is and there is an ode to
old-school gaming in that so it's kind
of you know you could someone who is a
gamer would see that and instantly
recognize that term but it's subversive
in that I mean in the game when you're
when you when your character gets like
you know when somebody knocks you down
the zero hit points you're you're you
know all of your your energy you've been
you've been okay you know and you're
once you read zero hit points you go
into a series of roles let's see if you
live or die
okay and that's what that's a reference
to number one number two I mean there is
a bit of a tipping of the cap or in
hopes of catharsis for the kids out
there who I knew many of them whose
parents and churches took their Dungeons
and Dragons books burnt them took their
Stephen King books and burnt them took
anything that had to do with magic or
the occult or fantasy or Ozzy Osbourne
or Black Sabbath and went and burned it
and said that you know Satan was
reaching out when if you listen to how
these lyrics Ozzy's talking about
running away from the devil he's talking
about not giving into it these games had
nothing to do with anything revolving
around Satan there were fear what they
don't understand and in religion you're
in a small little box yeah there was a
really shameful sixty minutes interview
of Ed Bradley back in the 80s where he
coerced parents into admitting that
their children killed themselves and
killed other people because of Dungeons
and Dragons there was never an apology
the you know which wasn't true obviously
insane I mean the West I mean we I play
with some of the biggest celebrities you
know my house in my home game
close their names no they're fine right
you know but like the West Memphis Three
they were they were put into prison for
murders that like if you look at the
evidence clearly they did not commit
these murders but because they wore all
black and they listened to Metallica
they were put in jail as scapegoats for
someone in the neighborhood who was
murdering children so you know I don't
what do I think that's about I don't
know
someone's excuse for bad parenting so
they're gonna try to figure out some way
something to blame mm-hmm
well we project you know what we're
insecure about so so this is like this
is actually an anti Satan front page of
an old newspaper that I am now it's
wearing ironically very appropriate I
think perhaps it's been subliminal
advertising that I didn't even really
recognize but or maybe it's just really
fitting for kind of the roads the you
know the line of our conversation I
don't know yeah what is our PG
role-playing game Oh real plain okay
this was like a manic role-playing game
horror this is this is the old satanic
panic Friday July 24th 1981
experts warn occult games infecting
minds of children yeah then this is the
actual article I think it took place
this is writing about Chicago and the
fear well let's face it Chicago is still
killing a lot of people in fact I think
they're leading the way have been for a
long time so I'm not sure that they can
say it was just the RPG not a Bears fan
I take it well definitely not anymore
and that's for sure Steelers fan you I
should have poured you straight vodka in
there just a little floater maybe you're
right
would you cheer for again yeah I mean
that you know a really good team mm-hmm
so why why did you do like what made you
feel like the clothing line was
something that was a good idea I'm in a
street where and I have been I always
keep up with with street wear trends and
like you know kicks and you know a lot
of some of the bigger brands a lot of
Japanese brands actually and none of the
Japanese brands make clothing or shoes
big enough for me yeah we've covered
that so so that was a big impetus I
wanted to I wanted clothes for yourself
I want a cool stuff for that I go where
- but then aside from that a lot of
street wear generally skews either
Japanese or hip-hop okay and they were
borrowing from the well of heavy metal
and and really deep fantasy but it was I
saw it being done in a way that was not
pure I guess they were kind of slapping
skulls on things just because it was
cool but they didn't really know where
that skull came from or what the origin
of that design was or that's actually a
knockoff of this artist who painted this
painting in the 60s and and then you
know or this album cover from the 80s
and I know what they all are so as a you
know whatever a fantasy heavy-metal
historian I thought well somebody needs
a new toy car I like it I like it
you know I thought well I could do this
right because I know III know the
progression and somebody needed to go
stick a flag in the ground and say we're
metal like this is metal this is fantasy
this is the real deal and if you're a
fan great and if you're not we're still
gonna make stuff so badass that you're
gonna want to wear it and so you know
right out of the gate I'd launched at
comic-con and good place for it yeah
people started lining up at five in the
morning why for a one o'clock drop doors
open of one were you there signing and
yeah I just said hey you know doors open
a wine and everybody come on out and
people started lining up at 5:00
there and the lines were three blocks
long in San Diego which are huge city
blocks so it was three gigantic city
blocks oh my gosh we saw that I feel so
good well yeah cuz I'm like I said
anybody gonna show up because we're not
in the convention where I'm asking
people to leave the Commission come
outside come to this store line up a
bootleg deal outside Comic Con was going
on in there I want you to come on here
and it was it was like it was huge and
people went nuts we sold out right away
we launched online the next day all that
sold out within days Wow like Wow okay
so so we're on something there's a lot
of people out there who have been
waiting there's something like this when
there hadn't been and a lot of the
artists that I use I use I commissioned
artists from around the world in all
kinds of different places have different
styles different feels and we I match
their talents with you know a certain
brand or a certain character certain
ideas something that comes out of my
head yeah this are you the creative
director for the line I'm a crazy
director yeah yeah I mean I did you ever
see yourself in that role ah no not like
I never thought I'd get in the street
wear a clothing I think like you know
being a clothing designer that's a
little too daunting it's not really
exactly the perfect definition on the
football team I mean you're gonna get
that title oh yeah why I'm known I'm
cooler but I mean I just think like back
in the day you know I wasn't funny you
are okay with being a Dungeons & Dragons
guy but not a clothing designer yeah
[Music]